an 8th grader from Texas is the
country's new geography champion 14 year
old prana Bharata took home the title at
yesterday's National Geography Bee he
beat nine other finalists Jan Crawford
was there and joins us from the National
Geographic headquarters in Washington
Jane good morning
well good morning Nora so nearly three
million kids in grades four through a
competed in this year's National
Geographic Bee but only the top fifty
four finishers from around the United
States and the territory's got to make
it to this week's national championships
here in Washington DC with $85,000 of
college scholarships on the line Kito
asunción montevideo victoria Tanganyika
Turkana australia after answering
hundreds of questions the country's top
geography whiz kids stepped into the
spotlight joined by the moderator our
own CBS News correspondent Mo Rocca on
the count of three the capital of
American Samoa one two three getting a
perfect score in the opening round was a
surprise for first-time finalist Ali lon
Iranian I don't really know how the
scoring works so I am pretty much like
what the heck but for Wisconsin native
Thomas Wright who last year tied for
eighth it was the end of a year-long
journey I know the expectations I need
to set for myself Washington DC at
national geographic headquarters
Wednesday junior geographers were
treated like celebrities showing off
their global knowledge under intense
pressure Rock Island and Buck Island
Reef National Monument are located just
off the coast of which Caribbean island
but with Raqqa behind the podium there
was still room for a little levity
Pranay do I stand a chance of ever
growing a mustache as full as yours
probably not probably the ten finalists
were eventually whittled down to just
two Pranay Bharata from Texas and Thomas
Wright from Wisconsin in the final round
varada and right matched each other
answer for answer Saint Martin is
correct so that means we move on to a
tiebreaker
and it took a sudden death match up to
put Virata over the top what large
mountains system that stretches more
than 1,200 miles separates the
Taklamakan desert from the Tibetan
Plateau the correct answer is the Kunlun
mountains so our champion is four right
a second-place finish was something to
be proud of I said the goal is the top
three finish with this year I mean I
accomplished the goal but of course I
would have wanted to win
what's your heart was racing or did you
you seemed pretty calm I was doing
pretty well now I'm more concerned about
my hair can be honest varada
finished just outside the final three
last year the day that you lost on this
stage last year
did you study that day yeah I was
researching and trying to find ways to
not make the same mistakes twice after
last year I was definitely sure that
this year would be the year I could win
this now for all his hard work and
dedication and perseverance Bharata is
going to take home a fifty thousand
dollar college scholarship and a trip to
the Galapagos Islands which by the way I
learned and covering this story is a
province of Ecuador Gael
there you go see what you learn working
for CBS this morning Jan Crawford you're
welcome thanks a lot
boy that's fun yeah I got me yeah I've
always wanted to go to the globe I've
always been interested in geography yeah
any more places off yeah and mo anywhere
you want get mo picking on the
contestant yeah yeah thanks nice job Bo